Well, hello again. This is Dr. Kevin Connors. This is part three of beating chronic Lyme talking about the three phases of Lyme disease
Wonderful information. So if you don't have Lyme disease, this might all be due to you. If you do have Lyme disease,
make sure this will be review, hopefully. All right, so we talked about the acute stage
last week in that many times it goes completely unnoticed. So the initial infection can go completely unnoticed and you can move many times.
I have patients that come in that are in chronic stage or autoimmune stage Lyme and they never do it.
I have patients that have had Lyme, that have had horrible debilitated symptoms for years and we discover its Lyme disease.
So I pretty much guarantee that a large percentage of people with AMS, large percentage of people with ALS, large percentage of people that have neurological symptoms, neurological inflammation,
neurological disorders, it can stem from Lyme disease. So in that never even crosses their might. So there are people died from diseases of different names that actually had Lyme disease.
So we talked about that acute phase so that there is a window. That window of opportunity to kill it with an antibiotic can be slim and it's different for everybody.
So it might be good to know a Lyme letter, a doctor in your area and develop a relationship with them even if you do not have Lyme so that you could use their services in case you have the symptoms.
We discussed again and I will reiterate my opinion is to use an antibiotic if you can communicate and have a relationship with a Lyme letter or a doctor even if you have the symptom story Lyme season.
Don't wait for the tests. The tests are highly inaccurate. We'll have a discussion just specifically on those in the future. So you can't wait for the tests.
So the second phase of Lyme, so the acute phase is the initial phase. That's phase one or stage one, whatever you want to call it. The second phase, phase two, stage two is called chronic Lyme disease.
And people can stay in this chronic Lyme disease stage this phase two for years, for decades. So they may never move to stage three.
In the chronic Lyme disease stage, it's defined by my definition as when any bacteria goes intracellular.
So when any bacteria goes inside the cell, now let's say the chronic Lyme disease stage. So you may have heard or maybe you or you know someone who was quote unquote cured of Lyme disease using antibiotics long term.
So they were on antibiotics for four or five years and they feel like they really have the Lyme disease licked and they are, you know, that was ten years ago and they're doing just fine.
That is true. You can't do that. But the problem is, is that once the Lyme disease goes intracellular, antibiotics won't work. But it won't work on the bacteria that are intracellular.
But as soon as it goes extracellular, it tries to reproduce and make you very sick. If you have circulated antibiotics in your system, it will kill it.
So if you're on antibiotics long term, that is another way to deal with chronic Lyme disease because you, as soon as that bacteria goes extracellular, you're going to kill it with antibiotics. The negative about doing that is that antibiotics are so harmful to the rest of your body to go on them long term like that.
If you're taking antibiotics on a ten day phase, that could be damaging to your gut, taking it on a phase that you're doing it over the course of years or months or years.
It's just horribly damaging to your gut. So it's not something that I would ever recommend. But I understand that people are desperate and they don't know any other way to deal with it.
But chronic Lyme disease is defined as the bacteria going intracellular. Once it goes intracellular, it can reproduce in the cell. It can damage the cell itself.
And it can then go extracellular. As soon as the immune system is suppressed a little bit, it goes extracellular and starts to reproduce extracellularly.
So a person typically has symptoms with Lyme disease that are undulating. That means they'll have some good days and they'll have bad days.
They'll have a little better day than that bad days. It is really on the better day when their immune system is firing up to kill that bacteria.
And it's cleared and out of the extracellular spaces. So they feel pretty good that day. And then their immune system suppresses as it's constantly in this uproar of a fight against this insidious bacteria that you have these undulating days.
And it's very confusing for the person.
In the chronic stage Lyme, it has yet to go to phase three, you could kill it with antibiotics. So it is possible to use antibacterials, I mean some herbal antibacterials in order to kill the disease.
So using cat's claw and different protocols by different practitioners that typically have a lot of different TH1 stimulators. So let me explain that.
So you have two sides of your immune system. We'll get into this in the next presentation in depth. But you have two sides of your immune system. You have your initial response immune system, your TH1 response.
That is the response that is the killer side. So think of your TH1 response as the marine core with machine guns. So they're out there looking for the enemy and they're going to kill the enemy.
The only thing the TH1 response does is kill things. So the TH1 response doesn't capture the enemy and bring it out of the body.
The TH1 response doesn't locate the enemy and make friends with it and try to communicate. The TH1 response kills it. That's all it does.
So you got the macrophages, the white blood cells, all these different TH1 cytokines and kibokines that they're only role in life is to kill bad guys.
So when there's a bad guy that enters your body, aka Borrelia Lyme disease, your immune system will fire a TH1 response in order to kill it.
The bad thing about Lyme disease again is that it's very virulent. So it's reproducing quickly. Your TH1 response is trying to kill it.
You can't kill it right away so it fires a greater response, a greater response, a greater response, hence you have symptoms of fever. So a fever is a hyper TH1 response.
You have swelling, you have fatigue, you have just, you feel sick, you have nausea, you have all these symptoms of a hyper TH1 response, better what the antigen is.
So that thing which the TH1 response is firing against is called an antigen. So Lyme disease is the antigen that we're talking about.
If Lyme disease hides inside the cell and your TH1 response can't kill it, that's not a good thing. So that's where you need antibiotics to help knock this down.
So antibiotics are coming in there as a false TH1 response, but they kill that bacteria directly and the immune system thinks it killed it, yay, it wins. So it goes back into normal and now your symptoms go away and you feel good.
In a chronic stage that Borrelia goes intracellular, outside of the space between the cell, inside of the cell itself, your immune system is firing a response, can't kill it, can't kill it because it's, it's not in the extracellular space anymore.
So it's anymore, finally it suppresses down and the Borrelia goes extracellular again, starts reproducing, making you sick, the TH1 response fires again.
So the purpose of taking immune stimulants like echinacea and garlic and a straggolus and elderberry and, you know, odd and odd and odd, any immune stimulus is to help the immune system.
And we're talking about, the immune system, we're talking about the killer cells, we're helping the marine corps kill the antigen. So the whole idea if you could think of it this way, when you take immune stimulants, you are basically arming the immune system.
So you are selling arms to the immune system in order for the immune system to have the capacity to kill the antigen.
Well that's a good thing right? Absolutely it's a good thing. If the, if the disease is still in the chronic state, that is a very good thing.
So a person that says, I don't know what your problem is Bob, I had Lyme disease and I took cat's claw for three weeks and then I took a condition and it knocked it right on me.
And Bob's going, well I did that and I felt better for a couple of days and it actually made me sicker and I'm still sick and here Bob's in the stage three auto immune phase.
But his friend knocked it out completely with cat's claw or elderberry or whatever little, you know, immune stimulant that he used, the reason why he knocked it out is that it was still in the chronic phase.
So, immune stimulants only work for Lyme disease in phase two. Say that again, immune stimulants, TH1 stimulants, which is known as anything that would be considered an immune stimulant.
All the medicinal mushrooms, all the different herbs, vitamin C, garlic, all the things that are supposed to boost your immune system, you could Google it, are all TH1 stimulants.
They are giving support to the marine core to kill the Lyme disease. They will only work when you're in phase two.
So phase two is chronic Lyme disease that's going that has gone into a cellular. Therefore, if you're going to use an antibiotic approach, it would have to be a very long term approach that would give you a lot of side effects.
You can use an immune stimulant approach if it's still in phase two. But once you move to phase three, once it becomes an auto immune disease, you're going to find out next week that you cannot use any immune stimulants at all.
Because if you do use immune stimulants and we'll hit this hard and heavy next week, you are healthy, you are armied your immune system. That's what immune systems stimulants do.
You are armied immune system to kill your own tissue. Not a good thing.
So when Bob could get better, take an immune stimulant, the kid figured out why his friend Sally can't get better, take an immune system. Sally is probably already moved into phase three.
Bob needs to stop being critical of Sally because Bob was able to catch it in phase two.
So just because something worked for you doesn't mean it's going to work for someone else. They may be at a different stage.
Got that? Say it again. An etymatics work in phase one. They can't work in phase two if you take a long term but it has a whole lot of side effects.
Immune stimulants work in phase two. They do not and you cannot use them in phase three because most likely, as you'll learn next week, you are T-H-1 dominant.
Immune stimulants work in phase two only in phase two. You cannot take them in phase three or you will be helping your body destroy itself.
You might as well just take poison if that's what you're going to do. Sorry, but that's what it is. You cannot use immune stimulants in phase three.
I'll explain that again next week. So hold your horses. If this is all due to you, listen to this again. I understand that.
So here's some immune stimulants. This is a great immune stimulant capsule. See, it's got a donation in there. Green T is a T-H-2 stimulant. We'll talk about that.
But a stragglers T-H-1 stimulant, Algarberry, Adagraphus, Immune enhancer, these are all T-H-1 stimulants, golden seal, all these mushrooms.
Quarter steps typically is on a T-H-1 stimulant. But should I talk you about it? I'll talk you. Rishi and beta-glucans are all T-H-1 stimulants. You can't take those in phase three.
But you can't take them in phase two. So, again, take hope. Treat chronic, treat acute lime in phase one with antibiotics as soon as possible.
If you do not, get a fairly instant relief of your symptoms. You probably miss the window or you're not dealing with Lyme disease. You're not dealing with the bacteria.
If you know that you're not yet in the autoimmune phase, that's phase three. If you know you're not yet in that phase three, you could try taking immune stimulants.
So they're great if you're in the chronic phase. Again, if you don't know what you're doing, make sure you call our office and you can talk to us. I hope you learned something.
I know we're going super fast, but for most, this is review for others. It's all new. Listen to it again. See you next week.